[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro de la grande interview on
va parler de la situation au liban pour
qui l'année 2020 aurait pu être un bel
anniversaire cent ans après la naissance
du grand liban à la fin du premier
conflit mondial
oui mais voilà le pays ami de la france
souvent montré en exemple pour son
équilibre est aujourd'hui ruinée
économiquement et socialement alors pour
comprendre les raisons de cette faillite
georges corm historien professeur à
l'université saint joseph de beyrouth
ancien ministre des finances libanais et
auteur du proche-orient éclaté aux
éditions gallimard est avec nous georges
corm merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation bonjour et bienvenue alors en
mai dernier le premier ministre libanais
a écrit dans le washington post
je vais le site et plusieurs libanais
ont déjà cessé d'acheter de la viande
des fruits et des légumes et pourrait
bientôt trouver est difficile de se
payer du pain alors aujourd'hui est-ce
que c'est clairement la famine qui
menace le pays
à quel est le quotidien de la population
au la population à un quotidien très
dure depuis longtemps nous avons
d'ailleurs la moitié de la population
qui est tombé en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté et nous sommes en train de
payer les conséquences de trente années
du règne de la famille haby alayli père
d'abord et puis sans suite qui ont si
vous voulez complètement permis un grand
pillage du pays qui ont signé des
accords de libre-échange n'importe
comment faire venir georges comme aux
raisons aux raisons de cette situation
aujourd'hui mais ce qu'on peut dire que
la situation économique et sociale est
pire que celle qu'a vécue le pays lors
de la guerre civile dans les années 80
les plus nourrir aujourd'hui la moitié
de la population ne peut plus aller se
nourrir aujourd'hui au liban
la moyenne
sur des difficultés de temps pour sommes
rentrés dans une période d'inflation
accélérée des prix et donc vous avez
alors énormément d'organisations
caritatives qui s'occupe de faire
parvenir de la nourriture en plus
pauvres
même le gouvernement a prévu une
enveloppe de 400 mille livres soit
l'équivalent de 100 dollars pour aider
les plus pauvres alors on imagine aussi
un que la crise du duc ovide 19 n'a pas
arrangé la situation est ce qu'elle a
été finalement un accélérateur ou alors
un déclencheur de la situation actuelle
n'aurait la situation était mauvaise
[Musique]
ce pays a été géré en dépit du bon sens
dur en iran depuis la fin de la guerre
civile comme l'a appelé donc depuis le
début des années 90 alors que le pays
était sorti avec une tête extrêmement
modéré tout en livres libanaises qui
était de l'ordre d'un milliard et demi
la gestion à des biens du pays a fait
que nous sommes arrivés à une tête de 90
millions de dollars
quand vous parlez de la gestion fond
c'est la corruption cette corruption qui
est dénoncée depuis l'automne dernier
dans la rue par là les libanais c'est la
corruption qui a mis aujourd'hui le pays
dans cet état où pas seulement pas
écouté on va moi je cite souvent le
président avait dit rafik le père quand
il est devenu premier ministre avait une
fortune de 3 milliards de dollars et
quand il a quitté ses fonctions de
premier ministre
sa fortune était de 17 milliards de
dollars
avec un un système aberrant qui avaient
été installés où on pouvait sans
emprunter des dollars à 6 ou 7% et on
est replacé en dans des bons du trésor
qui ont pu rapporter jusqu'à près de 40%
nous casser le système des systèmes
destinés uniquement aux élites
oui bien sûr mais faire vous avez aussi
des petits épargnants qui ont limité les
gros épargnants et qui ont se sont
empruntés au dollar en livres libanaises
donc ça me dit aujourd'hui que
finalement il y a de l'argent qui
circule tout de même au liban
ah oui beaucoup d'argent bien que au
contraire des mois et aussi des fuites
de capitaux massives et on pense
notamment que une partie des membres
elle aussi a fait a fait fuir pourquoi
comment l'expliquer
blé goudé le liban est devenu ce que les
appeler une banque au cra si c'est à
dire et régime unique dans le monde
entier
c'est l'association des banques qui gère
le quotidien de tous les citoyens vous
devrez aller à la banque et demander que
la banque
vous autorise à tirer tant de livres
libanaises alors si vous voulez des des
dollars c'est en forme beaucoup plus
compliqué vous devez justifier pourquoi
vous avez besoin de dollars par exemple
pour un pays qui a été un modèle liberté
économique et de la libre entreprise
nous sommes dans un registre bancaire
est sans limite alors on parle beaucoup
et également des coupures d'électricités
un quotidienne là-bas dans le pays en
quoi ces coupures d'électricité
finalement sont aussi le symbole d'une
corruption qui ravage la classe
politique
oui nous avons dû malheureusement navire
turc qui fournissent l électricité à
partir de la mer au lieu d'investir nord
dans de nouvelles centrales électriques
dont on avait besoin ou de moderniser
les centrales existantes et pourquoi ça
n'a pas été fait tout ce travail de
modernisation justement des centrales
électriques comme vous l'expliquait
l'instant mais parce que d'abord vous
avez des investissements massifs dans
l'immobilier qui est une forme de
placement l'ensemble des économies
arabes pratiquent à peu près d'après les
calculs de la commission économique pour
l'asie de l'ouest c'est-à-dire celles
qui s'occupent des pays arabes
environ 80% des investissements dans la
région sont des investissements de type
foncier vous pouvez les regarder en
egypte si comment on fait des villes
nouvelles moutons du caire tout le temps
au liban on a une anarchie de la
construction on a eu le caractère de l'
architecture traditionnelle a été
complètement supprimée avec une ce que
j'appellerais une violence inouïe
puisque on a dynamité à peu près 4 106
meubles qui avait un superbe caractère
franck ottoman et un lien pour faire
cette espèce d' espace qui ne veut rien
dire
vous avez cette société qu'on a appelée
solidaire qui s'est approprié ce pass
pour pratiquement trois fois rien
cette société qui s'appelait solidaire
de qui s'agit-il
avec il s'agit essentiellement de la
nomenclatura mise en place par le le
président alors le 13 juillet le fonds
monétaire international a mis en garde
le liban contre le retard de l'adoption
des réformes après un plan de relance
était fin avril
alors pourquoi aujourd'hui finalement
les négociations sont au point mort
qu'est ce qui coince finalement écouté
le directeur général finances est à
l'homme qui a prouvé sa compétence à
maintes reprises qui a régularisé
rétabli tous les comptes du trésor
depuis la fin de la guerre qui était une
entreprise herculéenne a présenté sa
démission récemment parce que justement
il a estimé que réels de ceux qui se
faisaient l'été l'été sérieux y compris
la façon de traiter avec le front
national
mais qu'est ce qui rassurerait
aujourd'hui le fonds monétaire
international pour qu'il accepte de
débloquer une aide
oui de toute façon rien ne pourra pas
être massivement
c'est en fonction des quotas du liban
fonds monétaire international qui est
évidemment tout petit mais
vous aviez eu le premier ministre et son
équipe qui avait fait 1-1 grands
documents sur les pertes subies par
l'économie libanaise au cours des
dernières décennies et sur la meilleure
façon de combler ses pertes
et parmi les pertes évidemment on y lit
à celles de la banque centrale du liban
qui a pratiqué des politiques qui ont
suscité énormément de critiques de la
part très nombreux économistes
mais il semble que la banque centrale et
est enfermé dans un monde à l ocab eu
l'air aussi elle il y a des circulaires
de la banque centrale qui qui sortent
constamment qui ne sont pas écrits de
façon claire qui peuvent donner lieu à
des interprétations différentes
donc tout ça met pas cette banque
centrale elle veut protéger ses intérêts
au fonds par la banque centrale on sait
pas très bien ce qu'elle a fait et elle
a fait des séries d'opérations qu'elle a
appelée financial ingineering générique
financière car qui a constitué à donner
des normes cadeaux aux banques
libanaises une autre aberration c'est
que la banque centrale a par les cadeaux
faits aux banques elle aura fait déposer
une grande partie de leurs avoirs auprès
de la banque centrale elle même ce qui
est là encore une autre aberration
l'autre anomalie est ce qu'on peut dire
juste avant la pause
en quelques secondes que aujourd'hui au
liban il y a les très riches d'un côté
et les très pauvres que le pays est
scindé en deux oui si ça a été que en
deux relativement simple à résoudre le
pays scindé
beaucoup d'organisations alors on a
maintenant des organisations de la
société civile qui sont très actives sur
le terrain pour obtenir des réformes à
pau à faire rendre des comptes aux
politiciens des différentes communautés
ce qui évidemment n'est pas pour faire
plaisir à la caste dominante
alors justement le système politique
l'organisation politique au liban on y
revient dans quelques instants georges
corm mais à fond on fait une petite
pause et bienvenue dans la deuxième
partie de cette grande interview nous
sommes avec georges corm historien
professeur à l'université saint joseph
de beyrouth
ancien ministre des finances est
libanais georges corm à l'instant nous
parlions donc du système politique
libanais on peut rappeler à sa
particularité elle réside dans le fait
que le pouvoir est partagé entre
chrétiens et musulmans je rappelle un
président chrétien
le président de la chambre des députés
est un musulman chiite le premier
ministre est un musulman sunnite ce
système qui peut montrer finalement une
certaine forme d'équité dans la
représentativité
il ne fonctionne plus aujourd'hui oui il
fonctionne très mal
vous avez partie dopé au public on
pourrait dire oh c'est l'opinion
publique des classes moyennes les
professions libérales qui veut en finir
système de quotas communautaires et il
veut bâtir un état de nature civile est
selon vous il faut il faut en finir
justement avec cet état communautaire il
est aussi à l'origine de la situation
actuelle selon vous oui oui j'ai
c'est un système de dépôt et après les
fameux accords de terre qui ont mis fin
aux quinze années de guerre civile dans
laquelle aussi et le nombre de pays qui
sont intervenus et est très grand et
libanais qui a le sens du mot à disait
c'est une guerre incivile ses quotas ne
font pas de sens alors évidemment on
pense que ces quotas protège les
chrétiens qui sont démographiquement qui
ont beaucoup décliné par rapport à la
démographie des com de la communauté
aussi bien sunnites que chiites mais on
peut voir une des plus petites
communautés du liban qui la communauté
druze qui continue d'avoir une présence
importante sur la scène politique
libanaise par exemple mais en tout cas
quel est l'avis de la population qu'ils
soient chrétiens ou musulmans
finalement avec la situation actuelle on
le répète très difficile proche de la
famine même est ce qu'ils demandent une
mise à plat totale de ce système est
finalement refonder une structure
politique différente
tout le monde est d'accord et fort il y
a même eu des essais d'instituer un
mariage civil et on a eu quelques
quelques lauder qui ont réalisé et
civils mais tout le système aujourd'hui
est bâti sur cette répartition reste est
un système de dépouilles dans les
fonctions publiques entre les
communautés
évidemment dans la mesure des
communautés a beaucoup changé
on est on est dans des surenchères
communautaire qui n'en finissent plus et
donc aujourd'hui si vous voulez
les contestataires le système qui sont
encore dans les rues et qui l'ont été à
partir du 17 octobre de l'année dernière
très fortement sont là avec on a eu
d'ailleurs de très belles scènes
derrière une chaîne humaine
il a perçu pays jusqu'à la frontière
nord du pays qui s'est tenu la main des
saints drapeau qu'on voit dans les
manifestations ce qui n'était pas un
qu'avant ce sont des drapeaux libanais
et non pas des drapeaux de partis
politiques
donc tout ça tout ça est intéressant
maintenant le fait que la population
vous pourrez enfin c'est la réalité
c'est que nous sommes soumis à l'embargo
inspiré par les états unis de façon très
claire pour que la population c'est
soutenir l'homme
le parti de dieu plus des américains
considèrent comme terroriste pour la
seule raison qu'ils la suite tenu tête à
israël et résister et l'obligé à évoquer
le sud du liban alors pression des
etats-unis sur le hesbollah on va y
revenir tout de suite justement parce
qu'on a parlé effectivement d'un système
financier défaillant avec de la
corruption à système politique et qui
finalement aurait besoin d'être changé
selon la population libanaise il est
aussi un contexte international vous
venez de l'évoquer les chocs multiples 1
du contexte régional
on pense aussi à la guerre en syrie plus
d'un million de syriens se sont réfugiés
au liban est-ce que là encore ça a
fragilisé à la situation dans le pays a
bien sûr et on n'a jamais vu un cynisme
elle qui refusent d'accueillir chez elle
j'ai envie qu'ils demandent aux
ministres liban rappelle paul et dix
mille kilomètres carrés et 4 millions
d'habitants qui me demandent de recevoir
est intégré dans notre économie
un million d'euros
et si rien plus cynique pas cette
attitude
je n'ai jamais vu alors qu'il vient
effectivement donc ce problème des
réfugiés syriens avec l'union européenne
qui les laisse finalement chez vous sur
vos terres et puis on va revenir aussi
sur les états unis et le hesbollah on
sait que le hezbollah est connu à
l'étranger principalement pour sa
branche armée sa position anti israël
vous le rappeliez il a réussi à
renforcer son pouvoir lors de la
formation d'un nouveau gouvernement en
décembre dernier est ce que cette
réalité là le hezbollah qui a de plus en
plus de force finalement dans le pays
est-ce que eh bien c'est ça qui mènent
les états unis à faire pression sur le
liban et le liban et la situation donc
actuel ou que l'on connaît non je dirais
que aulas n'a pas le sens de pressions
ou ne fait pas pression robic que par le
passé
[Musique]
aujourd'hui serait plutôt en retrait le
parti de dieu au liban parce que il a
aussi été l'allié par exemple du grand
parti de monsieur à bully kit a
longtemps géré le liban de façon
fantaisiste comme en temps de l'amour
remarquez tout à l'heure donc non il n'a
pas du côté de la 2de changement
simplement évidemment ceux qui j'aime
d'israël c'est la force militaire aulas
qui lui a tenu tête en 2006 et a fait
échouer sur l'invasion du rempart a
parlé trop biscayenne et c'est cette
oreille rolland pour moi
l'évacuation qui pond par israël après
des années et des années notamment
ensuite c'est des choses alors on peut
rappeler aussi que la halle pour
l'allemagne le hezbollah est une
opération structurante héros rist est ce
que là encore ça ça ferait d'un petit
peu les relations entre l'union
européenne et le liban nommé dans dans
le passé aujourd'hui l'allemagne cher
pour des raisons à mon habit liées à la
politique de longtemps voire la région
mais il ne faut pas oublier que c'est
l'allemagne qui a été un intermédiaire
très efficace en peu le res bona est
réellement dans des échanges de
prisonniers ou même des échanges de
combattants morts des deux côtés dont on
a échangé les les corps donc aujourd'hui
l'allemagne fait semblant d'être là elle
a traité
on ne peut plus avec lui on va s'arrêter
aussi sur la relation entre la france et
l'iran on se souvient de la relation
entre jacques chirac et hariri où il
suffisait d'un coup de fil peut
finalement pour résoudre les problèmes
pourquoi selon vous cette relation cette
proximité entre nos deux pays existent -
finalement proximité oui la proximité
entre la france et le liban
on peut citer le ministre des affaires
étrangères jean yves le drian par
exemple il a dit au début du mois de
juillet et des nous à vous aider
bon sang je le cite ce sont ses mots
comment est ce que vous comprenez cette
phrase non mais écoutez ici est vrai que
la politique ce n'est pas monsieur aller
les pertes mais par le fils et qui nous
a mené à cet effondrement financier qui
est à la source a été béni par la france
la france a fait et des conférences des
d'audi sport
paris 1 2
car personnellement avec d'autres
comment j'étais très hostile le seul
amauri tu gérer les finances du liban
pendant les deux ans j'étais ministre
qui était deux ans très difficile
puisque on avait la guerre au sud avec
israël pour qu israël est pas qu un bon
jeu les deux pas demander des deux
quitte ce soir c'était une habitude
chirac or any viennent de faire que le
liban le monde dit partout et je
voudrais rappeler que le liban a été
mais dans les années 50 60 et même le
début des années 70 c'était une économie
de productible parfaitement dynamique
c'est un pays qui a un potentiel
agricole massive extraordinaire qui a
beaucoup d'eau ce qui est rare
howell orient et qui a tout pour réussir
est-ce que s qui aujourd'hui la france
vu la situation catastrophique dans le
pays est ce que vous attendez
aujourd'hui de la france une aide est ce
que ces sondes de voir que tellement je
crois qu'il faut sortir de cette idée
qu'on voit tout le temps de demander de
l'aide
ça suffit au passé en deux si on
retournait au monde réel de la
production
si la corruption notamment diminué
aujourd'hui le liban à les ressorts pour
s'en sortir malien la situation le liban
a les ressorts pour s'en sortir mais
quels ressorts pour vous le liban est ce
que vous disais le liban un potentiel
agricole et industriel qui est
extrêmement important mais ce qui a
détruit ce potentiel
ce sont ces dizaines d'accords de
libre-échange a signé raphi israéli pair
avec le très nombreux états dont
l'arabie saoudite qui eux subventionne
athlètes vraiment leurs exportations
alors que
le liban ne le ne faisait pas l'accord
d'association avec l'union européenne a
été signé par monsieur amour avec comme
pour adapter l'économie libanaise de 10
millions d'euros
moi même j'étais en négociation
notamment pour avoir 400 euros les
différences de sidi lorsque nous avons
réussi à chasser l'occupant israélien
moi je vais demander à personne d'être
aidés ont au contraire j'ai fait baisser
les taux d'intérêts qui dispose d'un
logement et paix et le pillage du pays
cité par ce week end est simple que je
vous ai peut-être écrit on sent ddd
dollars à six ou sept hommes ont été
placés en bons du trésor en livres
libanaises qui ont pu aller jusqu'à 39
et 40 %
c'est comme ça que celle d'aix est fait
georges corm georges comme pour conclure
il nous reste que quelques secondes
comment vous est ce que vous voyez les
prochains mois les prochaines années
dans votre pays est ce qu'il ya une
figure un mouvement peut être capable de
relever aujourd'hui la situation
or je pense et j'espère qu'il aura la
même réaction que durant la guerre 75 90
et c'est à dire que les gens vont se
remettre à l'agriculture que les
industriels mon père des efforts avec
des encouragements de l'état
et c'est en revenant au monde de la
production que nous pourrons et en
faisant rentrer les réfugiés syriens en
syrie
ce qui semble vouloir se faire
actuellement
même si
nous allons avoir la communauté
internationale ont pris mais qui va
renseigner sur 6 mais il n'est pas
normal que nous continuions regarder un
tel nombre de véhicules merci infiniment
georges corm d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
je rappelle que vous êtes historien
professeur à l'université saint joseph
de beyrouth
ancien ministre des finances libanais et
auteur du livre le proche-orient éclaté
aux éditions gallimard cette émission
est à revoir sur notre site internet air
france point tv à écouter également en
podcast merci pour votre fidélité
à très bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]